[Music]
Abby Lee Miller says she's leaving at
Dance Moms your dance mommy's you don't
understand the tough-talking teacher has
affronted at the lifetime series for
seven seasons now but on Monday she
posted this to instagram saying she's
walking away from it all noting her
frustrations with how the show is run
something she also opened up about to ET
last month I have been doing all the
costume design making the costumes
running downtown buying the costumes
getting the parking tickets for seven
seasons now and unlike my account said
this is ridiculous you're losing money
you're wasting time and not getting paid
I getting budget from them but I don't
get a like salary to do the work so I
said forget it so I handed the producer
the main the main I handed him a the
check back today for the costume budget
I go oh by the way I'm not doing the
questions anymore seven seasons step up
the game people come on we deserve
something let's go you when you started
this did you think seven seasons we'd be
doing this would be a studio in LA I
never thought anyone would watch the
first six episodes I thought this is the
dumbest thing I've ever seen et has
reached out to lifetime for comment
[Music]
you